when we think about volcanoes we imagine
these eruptive hot violent gateways to
the center of the earth
and i spoke to a scientist who spends
the night in them my name is kent simms
and i'm a professor of isotope geology
at the university of wyoming ken studies
among other things volcanoes and it's
for a few reasons but one in particular
you can start to forecast this
likelihood for another eruption
to get his research data he has to spend
time in them sometimes overnight
so we're talking about what it feels
like
to spend the night in an active volcano
you're in a big crater it's spectacular
it's this is like being in a steep deep
canyon except for now it's circular all
the way around you there's a lava lake
below you and the summit is above you
volcanoes have a particular smell
because they're full of gas
those gases are very sulfurous so they
smell
um strong and accurate they also have
acids in them and so they're toxic the
air can be dangerous to breathe in you
know you oftentimes are wearing gas
masks but it's pretty hard to sleep with
gas masks
and it's noisy
it's echoey typically you'll hear
hissing
instead of a campfire
there's an active lava lake
looking at a lava lake is just
phenomenal that way it's mesmerizing and
there's something about the the red warm
glow it's unworldly
there's a lot to distract you from sleep
but sims says none of that matters
you you don't want to go to bed i mean
this is how the earth surface formed was
from volcanoes and if you're in the
moment
it's amazing
that's so cool
you